[Music]
this fries are pretty good it must be
made from Russian
potatoes Russia's the
[Music]
best H I'll handle this one relax relax
Red Guardian has this
are you relaxing it's very hard to tell
your eyes so angry like winter
Fox uh how can I help you officer just a
routine check in say uh where you fellas
headed uh uh uh sisters yes to visit our
sister it's her birthday you guys are
brothers what'd you get your sister for
her birthday cuz I cannot for the life
of me figure out what to get my wife for
Christmas television you got her a
sweater and a television wow that's very
generous nice story but where are you
really
headed step out of the vehicle and keep
your hand one who
hey really again with the guns that I
had wool over his eyes Target spotted in
Pursuit exercise caution but get them
get in cowboy let's go round up some
super soldiers stop with the bullets you
should dance with your enemies it is
like a great ballet of
[Music]
violence where did that come from did
you have that the whole
time no no don't shoot dance hey stop
swerving
[Applause]
I told you Dan come on man Dan
Dan a it's jammed you know what Carl
Mark said about
machines they make men
lazy stop stop it's over surrender
yourself the Red Guardian Never
Surrender
[Applause]
Dan Winter Fox and the
[Music]
red